el barco lleno de gran ucraniano sigue
su camino hacia el líbano aunque deja un
sinsabor para el presidente volodymyr
selenski y esta sonda hace poco gracias
a la onu en colaboración con turquía
tuvimos un primer barco pero todavía no
es nada pero esperamos que sea una
tendencia que continúe en total las
consecuencias de esta guerra son
horribles no sólo para ucrania sino para
todo el mundo serán horribles bone
machine el barco lleva más de 26.000
toneladas de cereales y tiene como
destino trípoli ciudad a la que llegará
entre 4 o 5 días precisamente allí hay
un barco atracado de origen sirio con
10.000 toneladas de harina y cebada
granos que según ucrania le pertenecen y
denuncia que fueron robados por rusia
durante la guerra algo que moscú niega
aunque el caso fue cerrado por la
fiscalidad del líbano ahora podría ser
reabierto
y
como saben el fiscal general se ha cerró
la causa penal basándose en algunas
investigaciones y pesquisas pero hoy
tenemos muchos más documentos muchas más
pruebas muchas más evidencias y ya hemos
enviado al fiscal generar la petición
oficial de reabrirla es muy importante
entender lo que
a pesar de la controversia a ucrania
dice que seguirá ayudando a líbano para
salir de la crisis alimentaria en la que
está sumido debido a la escasez de trigo
ucrania tiene para exportar un mínimo de
10 millones de toneladas de grano para
ayudar a reducir urgentemente su déficit
presupuestario que asciende a 5 mil
millones de dólares al mes